kurt why don't you tell everybody your
background so people know sure uh maybe
skip the part about you and your wife
mma ufc all that stuff but it's specific
to crypto uh so
2012 i was a um
i was a business owner i owned a
printing company okay
i was also big into the sound money and
the fed community and all of that in
chicago
i had a guy come to me and say hey man i
need some posters printed can i pay you
in bitcoin i said i don't know what the
hell bitcoin is he tells me well it's
kind of like video game money
i said okay well that that's whatever it
was like a 50 jobs i was like that's
fine it doesn't matter pay me a bitcoin
well that brought me the the first step
down the rabbit hole and uh by the end
of the next year i was running a small
mining operation and doing all kinds of
things so 2013 to 15.
i was big in the infrastructure space i
wanted to figure out like how does
bitcoin work but by the way when he gave
you that 50 bitcoin what was bitcoin in
yeah not even i think it was a little
less yeah so almost like a full bitcoin
at 50 bucks 75 bucks if i recall i got a
little more than one bitcoin if i recall
okay cool for a little stack of posts
today it's what 55k yeah the only reason
i know what price it was is because i
bought bitcoin in 2012 i told this story
before at a libertarian convention a guy
talked about i was like yeah i love this
and the feds grew fiat currency i bought
100 bitcoin for a thousand bucks it went
down to 900 bucks next week i was like
ah this is a scam and i pulled it all
out i lost 100 bucks i owned 10 big i
own 10 bitcoin and 100 bucks each
yeah that's my bitcoin story anyway so
yeah i mean long story short i got
involved in an infrastructure i wanted
to um i was a big fan of using bitcoin
as cash using it in the economy i i
believed fully in disrupting
business use cases so everybody wants to
talk about the finance aspect like hold
get rich all of that for me it was like
okay well what what inefficient data
silos and and all this different stuff
is out there that we can disrupt
so for me i was getting into development
like wallet development and all these
different things i i wanted to go that
direction and then what i like to call
the bitcoin civil war started around
2015 this talk about whether or not
bitcoin should be used as a business
tool or whether it is just simply a
savings or an investment technology
bitcoin civil war absolutely okay so who
is going against who so if it's north
and south what's the who's the enemy
here
the most basic way to put it is small
blockers versus big blockers
on the small blocker side you have uh
block stream lightning labs uh they're
they're primarily funded by a group
called digital currency group which is a
incubator owned by mastercard ventures
and they believe that bitcoin is a
an investment tool only buy it hold it
that's it if you want to use it maybe
use lightning network whether or not it
works is you know irrelevant because
it's primarily an investment technology
on the big blocker side
there's actually a couple factions of
big blockers that all kind of hate each
other too but there's the the bitcoin
cash community and bitcoin sv community
i'm i'm a bitcoin sv guy
um that at the time was uh roger ver
uh guys like craig wright bitcoin
unlimited um in 2015 the big group was
bitcoin xt so a lot of these people are
like hey we'll just create a bitcoin
implementation that allows miners
to to make a change uh when whenever
they feel like it if there's more
traffic they can raise the block size
and and just
go that direction like let's let's keep
fees predictable let's use bitcoin as
cash
and that became an increasingly
unpopular opinion and and the reason is
is because people just kept getting
richer by doing nothing and if you're
getting rich doing nothing what's your
incentive to maybe rock the boat to
maybe pursue some other avenue and i get
that but the problem is is all the
disruptive stuff happens when people
actually disrupt business and and that's
really what i want to see bitcoin do and
and really hasn't done that yet even all
the other blockchains that exist today
because ethereum is the one that's going
to do it no it absolutely is not
ethereum
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you